[Music]
what I'm going to talk to you about
today something we have not talked to
audiences about before so this will be a
bit of an adventure it's kind of I'm
going to actually talk about some
specific research which I've been
carrying out very very recently I will
have to explain a few technicalities but
I will try and do that in a way which is
not at all hopefully intimidating but
what I'm going to talk about is I'm not
just gonna talk about paranoia I'm going
to talk about extreme belief because we
live in a world in which extreme belief
is increasingly perceived as a problem I
certainly think it's a problem and
therefore we need to kind of understand
extreme belief I spent 30 years of my
career studying paranoia in particular
but I've been studying it in psychiatric
patients and I was flowing a bit about
that in a second and it seems to me that
an interesting question is whether any
of that has any implications for
understanding non next psychiatric
extreme beliefs or to put it another way
whether people like myself who are
interested already started out being
interested in the extreme beliefs of
psychiatric patients can learn anything
from looking at other types of belief
systems such as political belief systems
or religious belief systems so let's
start by thinking about pathological and
non-pathological beliefs so as I say
I've meant spent my life talking to a
lot of people who apparently have very
strange beliefs bizarre beliefs in the
context of a psychiatric clinic and in
psychiatry and clinical psychology we
call these beliefs delusions and we tend
to assume that delusions is sort of just
qualitatively different than other types
of beliefs so and they tend to have term
types of things so for example the most
common theme is a paranoid belief where
the person believes that they're being
persecuted in some way so I once had a
patient who said to me very quietly
Richard it's okay for you to admit this
I won't let on to anybody else
that you have admitted this but you know
as well as I do that the South African
service is out to get me don't you and
he this person thought of a South
African secret service had arranged his
a compulsory admission to a psychiatric
hospital next to a persecutory beliefs
we have grandiose beliefs so I once had
a patient who I should say just by the
way as a kind of caveat I'm no longer in
clinical practice this going back a few
years but I did have a patient who once
told me that he was the inventor of the
helicopter and the pop-up toaster and he
was outraged yeah it was sort of quite
comical anyway but he was outraged by
the fact that his millions which he
believed he was owed due to these
inventions had been stolen from ideas of
reference or delusions of reference this
is also quite common Tesco and the
paranoid belief first services the
patient who tells you that this radio
announcer of a TV presenter that message
is really specially meant for me okay I
know it's been broadcast of a nation but
there's a secret message embedded it's
for me erotomania much less common but
what quite well recognized so typically
the person that could be male or female
thinks that somebody who's you know
usually a movie star or somebody like
that is secretly in love with them and
the last one on my list he's peculiar on
delusional jealousy because you might
think the belief that my life wife is
about to run off with somebody is not
necessarily a delusion and it seems to
me it's a bit dodgy to think of it in
that way but it's certainly there in the
psychiatric literature sometimes people
say there are some people who say this
is the only delusion which is true in
reality because what tends to happen is
for a person with delusional jealousy
pisses off the spouse so much that they
do in fact run off and I actually had a
and actually although with solar
laughing about it it's a serious issue
because I actually had a patient who
exactly that happened to and he
committed suicide afterwards so it's
it's it's you know but we could if you
don't going to look far to find tricky
cases my favorite example of a tricky
case is describing this fantastic book
by john cracker called under the banner
of heaven and it concerns to more than
fundamentally
Rondon Lafferty who visited their
sister-in-law
in Utah in 1983 well their brother was
away and they murdered her and they
murdered his infant daughter and after
they were captured by police they've
made a very half-hearted attempt to get
away they told the authorities that they
were doing this at the order of Jesus
Christ and in fact one of them down
later said and still maintains to this
day he's in a Supermax jail now that he
is the prophet Elijah and he thinks the
walls of the jail will collapse and he
will walk forward into the work into the
world
Ron is on death row and there's a big
debate going on at the moment well
actually there's a debate of the trial
between mental health professionals six
mental health professionals testified
his trial three thought he was psychotic
three thought he was just in the grips
of an extreme religious belief and they
couldn't decide and that still going on
now because in America you can only be
put to death if you're not mentally ill
so there's a big argument going on now
about whether Ron is meant for you but
we all perhaps most people are more
familiar with the case of Anders Breivik
who similarly you know he carried out
mass murder in Norway and similarly
there was a huge dispute at the time of
his trial about whether he's meant for
you or not he said he was acting on
behalf of the Knights Templar which is a
secret organization and he was defending
Europe against feminism and
islamification and initially he was
diagnosed as psychotic and then in his
trial actually he protested that he
thought it was very insulting to be
called psychotic and he was found not to
be mentally ill and was found guilty of
murder so these are tricky cases and it
raises the question how do we know the
difference between a psychiatry belief
and an extreme belief which isn't a
psychiatric belief and the closer you
look at it the more difficult this comes
so there's a we call it the Bible of
Psychiatry it's think is the diagnostic
Statistical Manual psychiatric disorders
it's the American manual it's list
definitions of everything basically and
they tell us that delusions are fixed
beliefs on anonyme neural
in the light of conflicting evidence
okay when was the last time you had a
political argument with somebody and
ended with that person thumping
themselves on the forehead and saying
how could I be so stupid
they say the belief is held despite what
is clear a reasonable contradictory
evidence an earlier version of the
manual actually also added but the
belief is not ordinarily accepted by
other members of the person's culture or
subculture but that seems to raise the
possibility you could cease to be
deluded by the simple expedient of
hitching a truck a plane ride somewhere
to somewhere where you could find people
who would believe would agree with you
so this is you know it's very hard to
draw that distinction and it gets more
hard when we think about the kind of odd
beliefs which we all encounter in our
everyday daylight so paranoia remember
that's the most common type of
delusional system and psychologists have
recognized now for quite a while that
paranoia exists at a low level just in
the healthy population the normal
population my friend Dan Freeman who's
at Oxford University as this illustrates
it with this paranoid triangle he calls
it so the idea is that the tip you have
the extreme beliefs of psychiatric
patients but down at the bottom you've
got these what he calls social
evaluative concerns you know the sort of
thing where you go into it room like
this and you're looking at people and
you're wondering what are they thinking
about you say that sort of thing now
actually I'm not going to go into I am
going to explain some statistical stuff
but I'm just going to go flush up
something very quickly but don't read it
because it's a bit complicated but I'm
but basically we can test for that
difference if we've got large enough
sample and whether we've got a continuum
or two groups and I managed to get data
on about over 2,000 healthy people who
filled in a paranoia measure and about
600 patients it happened by almost by
accident we've done lots of studies and
we still arise we've got all this data
and we use three different statistical
methods to do this in each method
clearly show that we had a continuum not
two categories of people so paranoia is
more or less you know one end you've got
people who say things we sing like
really crazy like the South African
secret police want to do me in the bald
man you've got people are kind of boring
and somewhere in the middle you've got
people who sort of feel paranoid under
some circumstances or to some degree and
when it gets a bit high there it gets a
bit troubling to other people most of us
can think of people maybe we've
encountered in the workplace who seem to
make an impact
paranoid interpretation of every one of
everything I was once asked by a
journalist by the way if I would ever
hear experienced police nations my
response was no but I work in their
height in a British higher education
system so I count a paranoia all the
time it was the kind of quit but it's
sort of true so and that raises the
interesting question is is you know how
would we recognize it if we were dilute
everybody was deluded about something
maybe there are delusions which we all
have for modder bates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at iai TV
you